[Music]
morning ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the president yale
university the commanding officer yale
university naval reserve officers
training corps
and commander yale university air force
reserve officers training corps welcome
to the annual president's review
we specifically acknowledge and thank
representatives in attendance from
fairfield university
quinnipiac university sacred heart
university southern connecticut state
university
western connecticut state university and
the university of new haven
to you and to all distinguished guests
families and friends welcome
today's music is being provided by the
navy band northeast trident brass
quintet from naval station newport rhode
island
today's review is being conducted by the
midshipmen and cadets of the yale
university rotc
yes
present-day review have their basis in
both history and tradition
the mass formation of troops on one long
line at close interval made possible the
massing of firepower from muzzle-loaded
muskets of yesterday
in those early days the line of battle
was just that a line of two or three
ranks and looked much like the parade
formation you will see today the
adjutant forms a line for battle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
goes
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
watch
his head
ladies and gentlemen please rise for the
arrival of the official party
[Music]
yale university air force reserve
officers training corps unit detachment
zero zero nine arriving
yale university naval reserve officers
training corps unit arriving
[Applause]
arms
[Music]
yale university arriving
[Music]
i
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the posting of the colors
the national anthem and the invocation
[Music]
source
so
[Music]
battalion
[Music]
ah
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Applause]
restart
[Applause]
chaplain sharon coogler yale university
chaplain will now give the invocation
i invite you to join me in the spirit of
prayer
almighty god
source of all truth
here we stand
humbled by the breadth of service both
past and present in our midst
we stand proud of what has been made
possible because we have committed
ourselves to making our world a better
place
through our willing spirits
able bodies and courageous hearts
although today is a celebration and
rightly so
we remember those who have given their
lives in service to their country
and we hold close those who are
currently deployed and ask that your
gentle hand protect them
and guide them safely home
now may our hearts move from gratitude
to inspiration
as your divine spirit empowers us with a
renewed vision and purpose
let us begin this review
lifted by splendor
ignited by camaraderie
together in our many voices strengths
and faiths and as your loving people we
say
amen
please be seated
the pass in review has several purposes
first it serves to honor and thank the
leadership of the universities that host
and support our units
this event also serves as an opportunity
to publicly recognize the achievements
of the midshipmen and cadets you see
here today who have distinguished
themselves during the academic year
ladies and gentlemen commander
yale university
naval rotc captain wistro
[Applause]
[Applause]
good morning everyone
thank you captain may
good morning and welcome to our first
in-person president's review and the
first military pass interview since
april of 2019. it's hard to believe it's
been that long colonel george granholm
of air force rotc
and i are proud to recognize our cadets
and midshipmen for distinguished
performance to recognize our graduating
class of 2022 who'll be commissioning in
just a few short weeks and to thank the
many family and friends of rotc
i'm also excited that for the first time
in several years those yalies who are
part of the army rotc program at the
university of new haven are able to join
us
today before i introduce our host i want
to make some uh key uh i want to
recognize some key players in today's
ceremony
first off we have midshipman second
class aaron coo the midshipmen officer
in charge responsible for planning this
grand event and assisting from the air
force side cadet fourth class shannon
palm
my executive officer commander scott
ryan
first sergeant roberto portel master
trainer and enforcer of military drill
and customs
let me say again enforcer
tech sergeant patricia lozano master
sergeant shaniqua hunt
miss liz vilodaki
master administrator coordinator
ghost email writer etc etc
etc etc
also trisha neely ed walters carlos
pinella of pwg who has been instrumental
also in setting us up thank you for
being with us so many times as we
ventured over here uh to set this
ceremony up you've all been incredibly
helpful
petty officer second class michael
miragliata and the navy band quintet
thank you for joining us
captain may
our masterful mc who will keep this show
moving on or ahead of schedule
those who provide never ending support
to rotc for the sake of time um i do see
captain may i can see you from here
looking at your watch
i'll name but a few recognizing those
unnamed are just as important as those i
do name
rotc representatives from our partner
schools professor gary rose of sacred
heart university welcome
jason burke director of veterans and
military affairs for quinnipiac
university
president joe bertolino of southern
connecticut state university and of
course captain fairby of the university
of new haven army rotc program
from yale faculty and staff we have
president salovey president secretary
vice president goff cruz
dean chun dean levesque chaplain coogler
yva president adrian bondenberger yva
president sean flynn
also those representing our awarding
organizations who invest time and
resources every year undertaking the
important responsibility of recognizing
our students
last but certainly most important the
family and friends of support network
for our rotc students
colonel granholm and i thank you we are
proud of our students and equally proud
and appreciative of their supporting
cast
so let's give a big round of applause
for all of us
so please relax enjoy the show and take
plenty of photographs
at this time it is now my distinct
pleasure to introduce introduce our host
president peter salave of yale
university
president salve has a long and
distinguished career at yale he is the
23rd president of yale university and
the chris argeris professor of
psychology well known for his work on
human behavior uh human emotion and
health behavior especially his work
co-developing the world-renowned
framework called emotional intelligence
additionally
he is an uplifting and sincere leader
who always inspires and encourages
everyone around him whether their
faculty staff students
inspires us to work together in
strengthening our yale campus our
community and our world through service
to others
and these fine midshipmen and cadets
that you see standing before you all of
whom
upon graduation will take a solemn oath
of service to a higher calling to their
nation have benefited from president
salive's caring compassionate and
resolute leadership
so ladies and gentlemen please join me
in a warm round of applause welcoming
our host president peter salovey
thank you captain withrow for the kind
introduction
and for your service as commanding
officer of yale's naval reserve officers
training corps
unit
i'd also like to
recognize
and thank
colonel granholm for his leadership of
yale's air force reserve officers
training court unit as well as captain
farabee
of the army
reserve officer training corps
at the university of new haven
so now more than ever
we appreciate
your distinguished military careers your
commitment to
advancing stability
in the world through service
to all the parents and loved ones
active duty military members veterans
who are here with us today
i extend a warm greeting on behalf of my
colleagues across the university
and i wish to welcome cadets
liaisons and leaders from the university
of new haven
southern connecticut state university
quinnipiac university and sacred heart
university
we've all participated
we've all anticipated
the day when
public health conditions would
allow us to gather again
for special ceremonies like this one
and i'm so pleased that that day has
come
i'm pleased that for the first time
since 2019 we can honor
the hard work and dedication your hard
work your dedication
of our rotc students
here in person
our ability to celebrate today brings an
extra measure of enthusiasm
to a milestone
day
the sense of service we mark on this
historic occasion dates to the founding
of our institution
and to the republic
let me give you a few examples
in 1701
yale became the first american
university to inscribe service to
society explicitly
in its founding documents
scores of yalies have served with
distinction in every major conflict
since the revolutionary war
yale are gale air force rotc
was one of the original 77 senior air
rotc units established by an order
that general eisenhower signed
and yale was also among the initial
group of universities to establish an
rotc program
more than a century ago
army rotc
in 1917
followed by naval rotc
in 1926
and air force rotc
in 1946
at the time major general robert m
danford predicted the program would
become one of the many priceless
heritages
of future generations
at yale
and i look as i look out
in this amphitheater
i see
that he was right
the 42 air force cadets the 31
midshipmen and the two army cadets
currently participating in yells rotc
program
are carrying forward the proud legacy
of those before them
this includes the valor
of nearly thirty thousand
who served in the first and second world
wars
korea
and vietnam
and the spirit of sacrifice that links
these military men and women is a
hallmark of the spirit
of yale
itself
it is the desire to serve
to look beyond self-interest
it is the desire to contribute
to the common good
and it is in short the desire to improve
the world today
and for future
generations indeed
that is the call of the opening sentence
of our mission statement
this is the call
the class of 2022
has
answered your decision to serve our
country in the armed forces is
especially critical
during this period
of turbulence
we can see
today
the increasing presence of the spirit of
division around the globe
yet today
we've
as we salute your accomplishments
we can also feel
the thriving spirit
of the presence
and opportunity
presence of the opportunity
for service
it's a spirit forged over centuries
indeed the fabric of our nation is woven
by the individuals who have defended it
for nearly 250 years
their resilience their wisdom helped
build a nation and their strength
helped bind it together
during difficult times
their courage help save a world torn
apart by war
twice
their determination has protected
millions from a life of oppression and
hardship
their compassion
has brought food
clothing
shelter
and medicine
to those who need it most
and their unselfish motives in the face
of adversity brought hope
to those who are suffering
throughout
your time at yale
i have seen
the same sense of optimism
courage
and selflessness
in you
and i know the class of 2022
will manage to make us even more proud
in the years
ahead
so now
i'd like to congratulate all our
soon-to-be graduates
and express my appreciation to all our
midshipmen and cadets for their
dedication to service
and their many contributions
to yell
you will soon be second lieutenants and
ensigns
serving as america's ambassadors
around the world
you will face challenges and
opportunities in a rapidly changing
global climate
with incredible technological advances
that both connect people across national
and cultural borders
but also pose unpredictable
security
risks
you will experience shifts in political
and environmental landscapes
yet
regardless of what trials you may face
i am confident that you
like the generations of yalies who
contributed to this country
before you
will lead and serve
the greater good
we are so proud
of what you have accomplished here
we eagerly look forward to
all that you will achieve in the future
as you build on yells tradition
of loyal service
to community
and to country
i want to thank everyone for joining us
today
and i hope you
cadets and midshipmen
will accept
my
most heartfelt
and proud
congratulations
thank you very much
we will now begin with the presentation
of awards
the veterans of foreign wars award is
presented by mr dominic cortez
veterans of foreign wars commander for
the state of connecticut
this award recognizes one midshipman and
one cadet in each unit who demonstrates
a positive attitude towards rotc
outstanding professional attributes and
officer potential this year's naval rotc
recipient is midshipman courtney johnson
an air force rotc recipient is cadet
presley hill
the general society of the war of 1812
award is presented by mr lee trion
secretary of the society of the war of
1812 for the state of connecticut
this award is given to one midshipman
and one cadet who represent the
cherishing maintenance and extension of
the institutions of american freedom and
foster true patriotism and love of
country
this year's naval rotc recipient is
midshipman victoria imhof an air force
rotc recipient is cadet brandon estacio
[Applause]
the yale veterans association true to
her traditions award is presented by mr
adrian bonnenberger yale university
college 2002 and mr joshua ray yale
college 2013.
the mission of yale university is to
educate leaders additionally yale
university has a long and glorious
tradition of service and defense of our
country
the yale veterans association is very
pleased to present its annual true to
her traditions leadership award to honor
and commemorate these ideals to the
midshipmen and cadet who have
demonstrated a strong commitment to them
over the past year
this year's naval rotc recipient is
midshipman joseph murphy an air force
rotc recipient is cadet brian regan
[Applause]
the yale veterans network annual rotc
award is presented by ms tamika hollis
co-chair of the yale veterans network in
the spirit of the yale veterans
network's charge to connect veterans on
campus this award is given annually to
an rotc midshipman and cadet who have
demonstrated commitment to the yale
university rotc programs through
outstanding leadership discipline
character citizenship and academic
achievement this year's naval rotc
recipient is midshipman olivia plant and
air force rotc recipient is cadet
dominic defazio
[Applause]
the order of the purple heart national
leadership award is presented by major
daniel edinger commander of the military
order of the purple heart for the state
of connecticut
this award recognizes the demonstrated
leadership ability of a midshipman and
cadet enrolled in a university rotc
program
this year's naval rotc recipient is
midshipman catherine yang and air force
rotc recipient is cadet catherine yeager
the rear admiral frederick b warder
award for outstanding achievement will
be presented by captain vernon parks
united states navy retired the rear
admiral frederick b warder award for
outstanding achievement established in
1986 recognizes graduating nrotc seniors
approved for entry into the navy's
nuclear propulsion program as submarine
officers the awardee has demonstrated
superior sustained performance in a
difficult and challenging academic and
operational environment and as a result
has earned the commanding officer's
nomination for this distinctive award
this year's recipient is midshipman
cynthia framette
[Applause]
the corporal langdon laws ricketts award
is presented by mr adrian
bonnenberger corporal ricketts graduated
from yale college in 1916 and was killed
in action during world war one at mont
blanc in 1918. a decorated marine who
was a recipient of the crawda all
accounts maintained that corporal
ricketts had a knack for maintaining his
wits in the face of chaos
importantly he was an enlisted man a
non-commissioned officer
ncos are the backbone of the marine
corps more than any other service the
marines place special trust and
confidence in the abilities of their
junior most enlisted leadership
it is this sort of marine that the
recipient of the corporal langdon laws
ricketts award will be called upon to
lead shortly after their graduation from
yale college this year's recipient is
midshipman aaron coo
the hiram bingham third award is
presented by colonel grenell commander
yale air force rotc
in honor of the esteemed yale university
academic explorer and politician hiram
bingham iii this award is
presented to urge its awardee to always
fight for truth justice and mercy and to
serve as a reminder to them to fear
nothing except to do wrong
this award is given to the senior cadet
who exhibits the highest level of
integrity and american citizenship
this year's award recipient is cadet
julia sanderson
[Applause]
the robert n thug reward is presented by
mr kevin gunther united states air force
retired robert n tharp was an esteemed
teacher and mentor to generations of u.s
air force language specialists
this award is presented to a yale
university air force rotc cadet for
excellence in academic achievement and
for inspiring others toward global
cultural awareness
this year's award winner is cadet grace
zerba
[Applause]
the yale veterans association class of
1966 sword is presented by mr fred nagel
yale college 1966 chairman emeritus yale
veterans association
this sword is awarded to midshipman dan
nguyen an individual
naval rotc student who possesses a
demonstrated leadership ability and who
has earned the respect of yale
classmates inside and outside of the
nrotc program
through his efforts he has materially
contributed to bridging the civilian
military divide and by exerting
leadership in both spheres has enhanced
the prestige of the nrotc program on
campus and reinforced the yale tradition
of engaging in service to society as a
desirable life objective
[Applause]
the admiral david s ingalls leadership
award is presented by mr redmon s
ingalls yale college 1998 the admiral
david s ingalls award is presented to a
senior yale naval rotc student who shows
uncommon ability and leadership
potential
david s ingalls yale college was the
navy's first ace with five confirmed
kills in world war one
he later served as assistant secretary
of the navy for aeronautics where he
tripled the number of navy aircraft
while advocating for a fully deployable
carrier task force
at yale he twice captained the men's
hockey team this year's recipient is
midshipman sidney manzileski
the yale veterans rotc fund award is
presented by mr peter salivay president
yale college this award is given to a
yale senior in the army air force and
naval rotc units who is in good standing
in their unit with excellent academic
and military performance records
this year's navy recipient is midshipman
andrew song who is not in attendance due
to his naval reactors technical
interview the air force recipient is
cadet and northrup and army recipient is
cadet greg jazwinski
[Applause]
this concludes the individual award
presentations please join me in giving a
round of applause to our midshipmen and
cadets who are undertaking extra
academic coursework undergoing physical
training participating in numerous
community events and willingly have
pledged to serve their country upon
graduation
[Applause]
attention
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
we
[Music]
march
almost
tell ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we will now
recognize the class of
2022.
please hold your applause until everyone
has been recognized
midshipman cynthia fermet from
glastonbury connecticut of berkeley
college first assignment naval nuclear
power school of charleston south
carolina
midshipman sydney manzileski from
brentwood tennessee of silliman college
first assignment uss pinkney san diego
california
midshipman olivia plant from baltimore
maryland of timothy dwight college first
assignment naval flight training
pensacola florida
midshipman andrew song from palo alto
california of pearson college first
assignment naval nuclear power school
charleston south carolina midshipman
maelyn sorensen from new york new york
of davenport college first assignment
naval flight training pensacola florida
midshipman caroline thomason from
clayton missouri of morris college first
assignment naval flight training
pensacola florida
cadet miramar kalisto from los angeles
california of morris college first
assignment intelligence officer good
fellow air force base texas
cadet maria cannon from jacksonville
florida of davenport college first
assignment combat systems officer
pensacola florida
cadet dominic defazio from brussels
belgium of davenport college first
assignment pilot trainee shepard air
force base texas
cadet david gallagher from los altos
california of ezra stiles college first
assignment acquisitions officer
hanscombe air force base massachusetts
cadet emily heller from whitesboro new
york of the university of new haven
first assignment intelligence officer
goodfellow air force base texas
cadet andrew kosanovich from temple city
california of sabre college
first assignment pilot trainee vance air
force base
oklahoma cadet carson mesa from clifton
texas of saybrook college first
assignment intelligence officer
goodfellow air force base texas
cadet michael mohammed from new york new
york of the university of new haven
first assignment undergraduate air
battle manager training tyndall air
force base florida
cadet elizabeth nasser from boise idaho
of franklin college first assignment
intelligence officer goodfellow air
force base texas
cadet anne northrup from prescott
arizona of jonathan edwards college
first assignment pilot trainee columbus
mississippi
cadet shannon palm from guilford
connecticut of quinnipiac university's
school of law first assignment judge
advocate maxwell air force base alabama
cadet molly rogelstad from westminster
maryland of silliman college first
assignment air force health professions
scholar columbia university college of
dental medicine new york new york
cadet julia sanderson from centerville
virginia of brantford college
first assignment intelligence officer
goodfellow air force base texas
cadet matthew schneider from raleigh
north carolina of poly murray college
first assignment pilot trainee laughlin
air force base texas
cadet alexandra shore from washington
d.c of saybrook college first assignment
acquisitions officer hanscombe air force
base
massachusetts cadet rachel blumenthal
from bayside wisconsin of ezra stiles
college first assignment explosive
ordnance disposal officer fort lee
virginia
cadet greg jazwinski from milford
connecticut of poly murray college
ladies and gentlemen please join me in a
round of applause for our graduating
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please rise for the
benediction and remain standing for the
past and review service songs and
departure of the official party
my sisters and brothers let us go forth
from this place in peace
with wisdom and understanding with
compassion and mercy
with courage and commitment
may we be blessed
this day and every day by the shimmering
light of our god
who creates
sustains and embraces
all life
amen
uh
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dismiss your company
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this concludes
today's ceremony we invite all
presenters and award recipients to join
us at center court to take photos thank
you for attending and please join us for
refreshments in the lobby
you